في مخيم النصيرات منطقه مخيم اثنين
بالنصيرات قد تم استهداف هذا المنزل قبل
قليل من قبل ال طائرات الاحتلال طواقم
الطبيه انتشلت سبعه من الاصابات من النساء
والاطفال طواقم الانقاض الان في جوله داخل
هذا المنزل لتفقد وجود اصابات اخرى داخل
هذا المنزل
المستهدف سقط هنا صاروخ على منزلنا و زي
ما انت شايف الدمار والحمد لله على كل
حال غايا صواريخ الاحتلال التي سقطت هنا
في هذا المنزل حصت عدد الاصابات والله
عشرات الاصابات تقريبا فقم الانقاض هنا في
جهاز الدفاع المدني يعني تتابع هذا
الاستهداف وقوم بجولات تفقديه الان
للمنازل المستهدفه والتي قصفت من
قبل طائرات الاحتلال جزء من صاروخ يبقى
عليها الاحتلال وهو يعني جزء لم ينفجر
والطواقم هنا يعني تحدثت لنا بعدم الدخول
لهذا المنزل المستهدف حفاظا على سلامتنا
وسلامه يعني العمل حتى لا يكون هناك خطوره
في هذا يعني المنزل علينا وعلى الجيران
والاهل الموجودين وبنطلب من العالم يعني
تدخل سريع لانقاذ الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ
يعني دمار شامل هذا يعني حرب
اباده بمعنى الكلمه حرب اباده لا اكثر ولا
والمستهدفين الاكثر اللي هو المدنيين
المدنيين
فقط